do you feel like the article was a
little bit of a hippy though you know
that whoever wrote it was riding for his
son for like five years so it was like
oh what here's what happened it better
be exactly what happened for you to cut
off my little fun it better be the exact
thing to happen because your boys build
the momentum I was about to 70 truth you
a journalist friend of ours filled me in
the New Yorker fact checks everything
else around that's like their reputation
he just kept lying to them he kept
telling him all these stories as facts
and then nothing was adding up yo that's
a while to like hold on to the LIE
outside of the show